what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with spider-verse and here's a
funny thing this is going to be a pretty
short video relative to the other ones
that we've done because this is
basically part of spider-man team up uh
so these stories are not super lengthy
in fact they're like 10 pages each right
so they're they're pretty short here
what's funny about this one though is
this is probably one of the most
important moments from all of
spider-verse and so i don't really
understand why they shuffled it off to a
team-up comic and basically called it a
day right it's a little weird that they
did that but one of the things that had
come out of the scrolls that had been
given to the uh to the spider army by
the master weaver was the nature of karn
now we've talked about khan before that
he's one of the inheritors that khan
himself very much cherished love and
beauty and that unlike the other
inheritors he didn't feed on spiders out
of a desire to and so when his family
learned that they basically put this
helmet on his head and then banished him
from the inheritor home world destined
to essentially spend forever consuming
spiders in an effort to earn his place
back home the reality is that was never
going to happen but because of the fact
that the spiders have learned this they
see him as a potential ally because of
the fact that the enemy of my enemy is
my friend that karn hates his family and
his father most of all and so the
spiders can use that to their advantage
as a means to basically rally and bring
him on board so what we do is we switch
over to earth 3123 this alternate
reality where it actually turns out that
peter parker and uncle ben neither one
of them had become spider-man instead it
was aunt may which is cool you know
there's a few stories those guys who
don't know there's a few stories where
awesome stuff happens with aunt may like
you guys remember the golden oldie story
right where like aunt may becomes like
golden oldie she's a herald of galactus
it's amazing it's really cool she's like
babysitting franklin richardson like
galactus shows up out of nowhere and
then she like races off and like
chastises him and then like he turns her
into a herald and then like she goes and
finds worlds for him it's really cool
like it's a really really fun little
story but regardless this this
conversation between the two is actually
interesting because aunt may does
exactly what you would expect her to do
right i mean she's a kindly old woman
she's like a nice old woman that would
like fix your cookies and stuff like
that i mean she'll wallop you upside the
head with her purse if you're like you
know if you're mouthing off or acting up
right i mean aunt may's never afraid to
throw hands but the conversation between
the two
is such that she's a very gentle person
and it almost kind of begins to turn
karn for like a brief second but then he
snaps back and says no right destiny
cannot be denied i have to earn my place
back at my family just one more spider
that dies and then i'll in turn be able
to earn my place again right i'll be
able to be back with the family kind of
earn my right as i've desired it so much
now of course as you would expect you
basically end up having the arrival of
all these spiders who show up right so
you've got ashley barton you've got
spider punk you've got spider-man uk
billy braddock you've got spider-man
india you have like all these spiders
who show up out of nowhere and a fight
breaks out between them and khan now
here's a funny thing about this that
karn initially goes to attack all of
them right and we all know for the most
part khan could probably overpower them
right and probably even kill them but
right off the bat they take him by
surprise and the reason why is because
he says like i don't know how you guys
you know how you came here i don't know
how you got this knowledge that you know
you that i was banished from my family
and all that kind of stuff and it
doesn't matter he's like but but like
all of you are going to die and the
response of spider-man uk is like you
have it wrong like we're not here to
fight you man we're here to ask you to
join us right and initially the response
of karn is like man you guys must be
desperate if you're showing up here
asking me to join your ranks but the
funny thing here is that spider-man
india chimes in and says i understand
obligation to family better than most
but your family betrayed those
obligations long ago they claimed to
punish you for your mother's death but
the truth is they sent you away because
they feared you because you questioned
them and then ashley chimes in and says
the same kin folk who said that you
could come back and live with them like
one big happy family if you killed just
enough spiders and that was how many
hundreds of years ago the walls are
closing in like their argument is
there's nothing you can do here that
will make your family proud there's
nothing you can do to earn your place at
their side that's never gonna happen
that's never ever ever gonna happen like
there's nothing you can do here your
family will always have you as a carrot
on a stick right just keep going a
little bit longer and you'll get it
right they're literally just leading you
on and so either you can stand aside
from that you can stop that or you can
keep it going and one of the funny
things is they kind of tease this way of
saying like you you know they have like
another way for him to continue to
survive and where the answer that that
that anyaka raising gives us no we don't
but your family if you help us beat them
we could use their technology to find
alternatives to you traveling around the
multiverse and consuming spiders then
right off the bat karn snaps back right
this little glimmer of hope that he
thought he had he snaps back and says no
no that's never gonna happen i've got to
keep doing my thing right in a lot of
ways it's like a video game right where
you have to go through like those trust
challenges where you have to like
convince them into believing you and if
you answer any of the questions wrong
then like they're like no i can't trust
you you know you guys know what i'm
talking about like star wars knight to
the old republic is a really good
example of that where karen says it's
useless to defy fate the natural order
spider-man uk says who says there's only
one natural order how many worlds have
you been to i've seen multitudes they're
all beautiful and they're all different
according to the scroll you wanted to
explore their beauty record it celebrate
it not bring death and destruction and
then anja chimes in and says and as for
fate who knows more about it than the
master weaver and who do you think gave
us this and so when the statement's made
like the master weaver is the reason why
we have these scrolls in the first place
it kind of begins to lock things in
stump because while karn has been
banished from his family for quite some
time the basic functions of the family
and the nature of the master weaver
that's still known to him and again one
of the things that we've stated is that
while the master weaver doesn't tell
them walk this way and then turn left
you know or follow this exact path and
you will end up where you want to go he
doesn't lead them to their future the
master weaver does have knowledge of the
future and so what their response is the
master weaver gave us these scrolls and
in giving us these scrolls gave us this
knowledge of you so we could tell you
that we have this knowledge so we could
ask you to work with us that it's all
basically fate that karn was destined to
turn away from his family and to join
the spider army against the inheritors
this is a big ally for a variety of
reasons the first is because despite the
fact that karn has been gone for a
lengthy amount of time there's still
some very important information he can
give the spider army to help him defeat
his family their inner workings how they
function all that kind of stuff any
information that they don't have no
matter how small is exceedingly
important in this war that they're
engaged in the other part of this is
that karn says my hunger can be intense
it can be uncontrollable there are times
when i'm going to need to feed and the
response of these guys is okay then if
that's the case and this is a big risk
that we're taking here we'll let you
feed on us not enough to like kill them
right but enough to basically sustain
himself and that's what happens right
khan comes with this realization he says
all this time it was a lie the centuries
i suffered the pain i inflicted none of
it had to happen my family told one
truth there is no greater wretch than me
and so the response of spider punk is no
one is beyond redemption it will be a
long journey but that is nothing new to
you is it let us help you take the first
step this is an important thing because
it feeds into the nature of the spider
army the various spiderman themselves
right one of the things we didn't
necessarily cover in the previous video
it didn't seem overly important is that
there is a point where spider-man india
has this bit of a kind of an emotional
breakdown where he seems to come to this
realization that when he looks at peter
parker that all their differing names
and even their costumes seem to be
alternate variations of peter parker
himself that they're all basically
copies of peter parker and in a lot of
ways that's true but that's the common
theme that spider-man more often than
not share it's one of the things that
made ashley barton and superior
spider-man so unique is that they were
kind of an answer to the question what
happens when somebody becomes a
spider-esque character but then is kind
of a villain and then maybe kind of a
hero but is usually a jerk more often
than not but they aren't straight true
villains i mean i guess maybe ashley
barton is she kind of became the new
kingpin in old man logan but outside of
her
you know superior spider-man isn't
necessarily a straight villain he kind
of was in the beginning but he changed
his ways as time went on and that's kind
of the nature of what it means when it
comes to the spider-man mythos is
they're not necessarily naive i mean in
some ways they are right the belief that
like everybody can be saved if you just
show them happiness and help them
understand their hearts are three sizes
too small you know like if you if you
approach it from that perspective sure
right that's just that's just good old
plane being naive you know and so with
these different spider-man sure like in
this instance if this were anybody else
they probably would have pummeled them
but the fact that karen is someone they
need on their side that they're able to
bring in this sort of gentler touch that
can kind of rally him in and say look we
need your help in defeating the family
that you hate so much and so as a result
of this they actually all end up
basically grabbing karn and sharing a
bit of their power with him which kind
of allows him to feed and sustain
himself to a degree not enough that it
like kills anybody but enough that like
he's able to kind of keep himself going
and then following that they exit
through the portal and take karn back to
their base of operation so again an
exceedingly important story in the
spider-verse event which was just kind
of shuffled off to a side story and i
never completely understood why but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace